let's try the seven to zero area code
caller from seven to zero tell us who
you are where you're calling from go
ahead hi this is a Sean from Denver so
and so forth and I'm just calling to
make a comment about like the current
condition of the media so on so forth
and why why organizations like you are
important but more so than that why we
need to hold the people on like CNN and
MSNBC to higher standards because like I
was recently watching Alexandra Eric on
Joe Cortez interview with Jake Tapper
and what's really happening is because
of the fact that people who are being
interviewed never give any pushback to
the interviewer like hey what about CNN
and your ties to the pharmaceutical
industry or your ties to you know oil
companies or or just your ties to like
politicians all and so forth like is
there any particular reason that you may
be asking these questions because as it
is now the narrative is constantly being
set up by the people asking the
interview because they're framing every
question and if we don't fight against
that if the people who go on there and
talk they're don't fight against the
inherent narrative we will not be able
to win in any capacity because of the
fact that people think that they're fair
questions because they think they're
listening to an objective person but in
reality they're perpetuating and
narrative simply through their form of
questioning like yeah yeah I get it so
okay very very good so a few things
number one I agree with you completely I
agree with you completely what I want to
let you know about though is that there
is some limit to how much you can do
that before you basically bring the
interview to a grinding halt which maybe
is what you're trying to do but like
let's play it out a little bit right
Jake Tapper asks her a question and says
you know your position on health care
are you really a single-payer that would
be bad for this that she goes listen
Jake CNN which employs you and pays you
a whole bunch of money takes tons of
money from those corporations so aren't
you just a biased shill because your
salary is paid for by the pharmaceutical
companies that you're trying to defend
by asking me this question and like okay
I I think that's great I love it I think
that that would work but then he can say
well regardless I want to hear from you
because you're running for a position
and I want to hear how you're gonna get
single-payer health care like it only
works so much if you have an experienced
interviewer that's not a critique of
your idea like I'm a hundred percent on
board with your idea in practice though
having been on both sides of interviews
you can bring the interview to a
grinding halt but then like the segment
will just be ended early and you know I
don't know how much you'll get versus
Alexandria Ocasio cortes spending the
whole time she could have trying to get
people to vote for her versus
short-circuited the interview and I
absolutely agree with that like the
interviewer like I'm they blacklisted
burning completely so I have no
disillusions about that but I think you
could you could be more finesse about it
like hey you know at the end of the day
like you know you're asking all these
questions about who you're gonna pay for
why is it like you don't ask the
Republicans how you're gonna pay for it
so on and so forth you could push you
could push a narrative you know II mean
from a particular way of equality I mean
we know it's not equal but if you push
that narrative in that capacity like
this is something I really care about
like I don't hear you know CNN talking
about like these issues that are
important to Americans but you know like
are you gonna ask the Republicans
because I've seen on CNN like you don't
ask these questions Ahnold Trump you
know I tell ya know that second question
is a better one and that that's much
better because you're not
short-circuiting the interview in the
same way that some of the early ones
would but I think every day all
progressives who are going to be
interviewed should be it should be
prepared to answer those or to ask those
questions and know how to answer them as
well and redirect Sean thanks for the
call really appreciate it